while and do-while loops are very
similar they both allow you to repeat
code the while loop I have an example of
that right here the while loop creates a
loop that executes a specified statement
as long if the test condition evaluates
to true and the condition is evaluated
before executing the statement so while
it is less than 5 what wallace is true
it's gonna run all these statements in
in the curly braces and in the
statements it's going to add 1 to n and
it's going to cancel that log in equals
n so the important thing to know about
while and do-while loops is that it's
not automatically going to increment
your counter like like what happens in a
for loop so you have to make sure you do
that right inside the loop the dowhile
loop is extremely similar except this is
going to create a loop that the execute
until this test condition evaluates to
false so the condition is evaluated
after executing the statement resulting
in this these statements these are going
to run at least one time so it's going
to do this stuff right here while I is
less than 5 and then when I not less
than 5 anymore it will stop so one of
the key differences is that this is
always going to run at least once it's
always gonna do this whole thing here
and then see if I is less than 5 and
then if that is we'll stop here it's
going to check if n is less than 5 at
the beginning and if it is it's going to
run this code in here so let me run it
now so you can see what happens so you
can see N equals 1 2 3 4 5 I equals 1 2
3 4 5 now that looks exactly the same
but now if I change this in to 5 so it's
going to start at 5 it's gonna be while
in is less than 500 and it's already not
less than 5 so it's not going to run
this but here it's going to run this
whole thing
then it's going to check if I is less
than five and it's going to stop so
let's see that see it just says I equals
six which is we would even have I equals
six last time but remember I is gonna
start at five it's going to increment go
up one and they want to consult it's
it's six and I'm going to stop because I
is not less than five so while I is less
than five well I is not less than five
so it's gonna stop so let's change this
back to zero and I'll just show you a
few more quick things you can also use
break and continue so if you use
continue if N equals three okay we have
n if N equals equals three then continue
the continued command means to not run
any code after that command just go to
the next iteration of the loop so if you
have continued it's going to skip
anything below the continue is gonna
skip this it's just gonna go back to the
top and do another check if n is less
than five and then it's going to
increment in again so let's see that
okay
look right here N equals one N equals
two and does not equal 3 N equals four N
equals 5 because it's skipped N equals
three if you use break here break is
going to just jump out of the loop
completely so it's not gonna run any
more iterations of the loop so let's see
that okay right here with N equals one N
equals two we don't have any query you
don't have N equals four we don't have N
equals 5 that's broken out of the loop
now here's a protip if you accidentally
make a loop that goes forever and then
your code and then you run the code your
browser could freeze up this is called
an infinite loop and it could crash your
browser if you're using Chrome the
solution is to click window in the top
bar and then go to the task manager and
then in the process and other browsers
have a similar thing and then if you're
using code pin like I'm doing the
default setting is that the JavaScript
runs automatically as soon as you go to
the page and this could cause your
browser to freeze up again if it runs
the same info
loop again so if you know your code as
an infinite loop add the following to
the end of the web address bar the
question mark turn underscore underscore
JX equals true and then if you add that
to the end of the address bar it's not
going to run automatically you may have
to instead of putting a question mark
here you may have to put in and sign if
you already have a question mark in your
address bar
well that's while and do-while loops
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good